what I'm on this side Oh weird huh if
you're new it's it's nothing different
for you guys got some more DC movie news
for you all which I'm sure you've
already heard Joss Whedon he has left
writing interesting back girl says he
didn't have a story here's the full
quote John you want to read it sure
fat girl is such an exciting project and
Warner's DC's such collaborative and
supportive partners that it took me
moments no it took me months to realize
I really didn't have a story I'm
grateful to DC president Geoff Johns and
Warner Brothers picture group president
Toby Emmerich and everyone who was so
welcoming when I arrived and so
understanding when I is there a sexier
word for fail well at least this time
Joss Whedon's actually taking a break
away from superhero movies like he's
been wanting to you did the Avengers
movies he worked on agents of shield he
seemed like he was just ready to die and
then he steps in for Batgirl but then he
takes over Justice League yeah yeah I
think he's had enough superhero for one
lifetime I think he needs a good long
break I think he needs a good break just
work on his own original material right
now and I actually am okay with this
news I respect it was that excited for
Joss Whedon to do a Batgirl movie hell
yeah I thought he was actually a great
fit for it you know there's some things
you could obviously consider that might
have been a bit of an upset the fact
that it's Joss Whedon with and also a
divisive figure it's a divisive figure
and he's such a Marvel name you know
like so much of Marvel's associated with
him in some retrospect to bring him over
to DC would but already people were
already complaining that Justice Lee was
already trying to feel a little bit more
like a Marvel film also you know they
could patty Jenkins being like the big
female director for Wonder Woman and
Batgirl being directed by a dude I'm
sure would have had some of its own
upset around the time of the movie's
release
yeah I'm not super upset about this I
feel like maybe ten years ago I would
have been like goddamn but now I'm like
cool they can get a woman maybe yeah to
make Batgirl I don't feel like this
really spells out trouble because since
the first Avengers the quality of Joss
Whedon's comic book movies hasn't been
as high up is that this isn't a project
but I don't think somebody else could
easily come in and tool around and I and
I like think he just admit he's like I
just I don't have a story I don't have a
story I mean that's that's one of the
best things you can do honestly
trapping yourself into a couple years
worth even though I'm gonna make this
clear again I really did love my
experience watching Justice League
obviously the film was rushed and they
could have delayed the release to smooth
out and fine-tune they wouldn't have
it's impossible impossible to do those
doesn't happen so for him to just say
like hey I don't have a story I want to
waste anyone's time that actually brings
a level of comfort to me you know that
they're not trying to just push
something even they don't have something
you know the smart decisions yeah cuz I
mean often our movies just shoved into a
freakin release date and a pipeline
because they just have to do it's
reassuring to know that this guy stepped
away because he just couldn't come up
with something and it would have been
something forced if he probably did do
it well I mean we've seen what happens
when Joss Whedon is not and I don't
think anybody wants that and I don't
really see any other bigger conspiracies
behind this story that I'm sure some
people are speculating on with the
lackluster performance of Justice League
and how the reshoots went and all that
crap I don't think it has anything to do
with that I really think it's just
because a guy didn't have a story yeah
yeah for sure because Justice League is
an well-documented enough Frankenstein
that we get it like that even if you
wanted to take the quality of that movie
out on Joss Whedon you you kind of have
to know that he inherited something that
was already there I feel like it's blank
slate time moving into a new more
original territory like that girl yeah
just the same I'm just glad somebody
made a wise choice they should get the
woman that was originally courted to
direct black panther yeah I was doing a
wrinkle in time Ava Duvernay
Ava Duvernay they should get her or
Oprah yeah oh brother
Oprah scorn for everything now yeah we
can do anything I mean any job you've
got just give it over it was a pretty
good female directors Angelina Jolie I
think she might be a pretty good choice
actually - maybe helm aback girl movie
actually can play Batgirl she looks
great for like 68 or
yeah well you know it's all these kids
that she didn't have herself I'm kind of
more excited now because I'm a little
sick of seeing Joss Whedon try to keep
superhero [ __ ] together
although the DC universe of the movies
is just more fumble than ever it was
just like a couple days ago when they
said the next movies are probably gonna
be Batgirl and flashpoint and then Oh
Joss Whedon left back girls they don't
have a writer director for Batgirl now
this is all potential baby look at me
it's par for the course for them but I
don't think it's catastrophic in any way
it's not like a lot of the other news
we're used to hearing out of DC yeah I
think what DC should just do is really
stick to their standalone movies a
little bit more you know I have faith
Aquaman's gonna be pretty good it's
James Wan and Jason Momoa seems like
he'd kill it as Aquaman I really liked
him in Justice League despite you know
whatever like did he actually serve
point and Wonder Woman was great and I
think Man of Steel was an alright film
but it's like the it's the mashup ones
like BBS steel and I feel like Aquaman
will probably be pretty solid film too
so I think what DC has to do to
course-correct is just you know you
don't have to reboot the whole thing
just stick more to your standalone films
for now because it seems like that's
where your best bets at Joss Whedon has
had the worst comic book store ever just
behind the scenes he's played with bad
luck this guy I feel like like like like
time has kind of soured for Joss Whedon
in recent years ever like Avengers was
like at the closing of a chapter and
then like vendors to and and just saying
like the whole thing with his wife and
it's like personal life finding out like
oh [ __ ] you're not like the gleaming
knight of feminism we all thought like
you know you got some good ideas but
also you got some shoes every time I
hear news about him now I'm always a
little bummed just like a man nineties
it's all just gonna come back pretty
soon so I say just work on another Buffy
story why not go for it
rebooting rebooting yourself either way
all right guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and check out our
patreon weekly Q&A is full video
reactions to TV shows and music videos a
whole bunch of goodies over there